et voilà bureau des objets perdus
j'ai cherché les noms arrête ça
m'étonnerait qu'ils retrouvent aux
écoutes françois ne soit pas méchant je
suis sûr que je vais ranger quelque part
je ne sais pas si c'est sur une étagère
et julie judas mais je n'ai hélas perdu
et il a perdu et que non excusez moi de
me mêler de votre conversation
bonjour 15 et meyrin bonjour bonjour 1
mais il me semble vous avoir entendu
dire qu'un julie avait perdu quelque
chose c'est quasi mais julie perd
toujours quelque chose contre toi ne
soit pas un juge ça arrive à à n'importe
qui de perdre quelque chose alors bravo
bureau des objets perdus d'occasion kg
casimir on retrouve tout même le sourire
ragot voilà une excellente nouvelle et
une bien jolie forme et les stars et
puis avec julie tous les jours tu auras
une fidèle fidèle clientèle ou trois
soirs si tu conduis moi j'avais plus
grand calme du caou du calme des émirats
parfaitement raison gardons notre calme
alors il faudrait savoir vous l'avez
perdue vous voulez garder
mais votre car nous voyons pas scott si
vous avez perdu dans ce cas là il faut
que je regarde dans ma liste rose si
j'ai cet article a par contre si vous
voulez le garder c'est pas la peine de
me faire perdre mon temps
moi aussi j'ai perdu quelque chose ça
alors excusez moi il faut que je garde
dans ma liste alphabétique mon temps en
temps tu en es technologies j'ai pas
perdu la tête un temps mais non non j'ai
pas de temps à perdre à fabas casimir je
suis tout à fait ton avis et si tu veux
que ton bureau des objets perdus que
donne entière satisfaction je ne donne
rien je vends au casimir j'ai
l'impression que tu mélanges tout dans
dans ta tête
tu prends ça eh bien tu te trompe parce
que moi je sois organisé ne suis pas
comme julie écoute casimir si tu deviens
aussi désagréable que françois moi je
parle et mange
regarde françois tu vas voir à quel
point je suis organisé crié je regarde
j'ai un cahier bleu pour les machins
donc à heroes pour les trucs pour les
traits sont par exemple si tu as perdu
un pot de moutarde je regarde dans la
liste des trucs 1 si tu as perdu une
occasion de se taire je regarde dans les
machins
casimir j'ai l'impression que tu ne fais
pas la différence entre concret et
abstrait mais qu'est-ce que c'est mais
c'est pas difficile le casimir quelque
chose de concret c'est par exemple un
objet les choses qu'on te toucher on
peut voir quelque chose de matériel ont
contredit peu quelque chose d'abstrait c
c'est une manière d'être une qualité en
bon à défaut la sagesse la paresse etc
je vais appeler les enfants ils vont
aider on s'en venait peut-être peu mais
vite casimir a besoin de nous rails
casimir a écrit dans de liste des mots
concret il est non abstrait il les a
complètement mélangé à vous allez les
baies d'accord et vous si chez vous vous
cherchez avec nous d'accord alors voyons
sa première liste kazemi une baignoire
inculqua c'est un nom concret le concret
oui du fromage à la chan c'est qu'on
craque enfin il y aura t il lieu de dire
des bêtises et que devient les réponses
des enfants dorment à la dignité
c'est un art abstrait l'amour propre
c'est vrai aussi l'amitié viendra
abstrait
l'autre liste de casimir bonbons c'est
un nom très concret mais c'est très bon
même la peur
c'est abstrait une table c'est concret
l'émotion a trouvé une paire de
chaussures
merci les enfants vous avez bien aidé
casimir merci j'ai enfin compris
gelli
julie tu l'as toujours pas retrouvé non
non non et non enfin grâce au bureau des
objets perdus de casimir je trouverais
peut-être une solution tout l'espérons
voilà quasiment figure toi que je
voulais offrir à quelqu'un pour sa fête
d'un petit sac de dragées au poivre et
pièces je les perdais faire du bon alors
perdu un sac de dragées au poivre sat de
trajet au poivre voilà mais c'est tout
ah oui c'est tout si tu veux leur
prouver cet autre chose dans ce cas là
il faut s'adresser au bureau les objets
trouvés mais on a mal renseigné lui
c'est très ennuyeux sa quasi mais parce
que je ne voulais pas traiter mais c'est
à toi que je voulais offrir ces petits
sachets d'ouvragé au poivre alors le
temps d'y aller au bureau des objets
trouvés la fermeture sera déjà fait et
ça sera trop tard
mais oui casimir tu pourrais peut-être
nous expliquer comment nous y rentre mes
anges en nous dépêchons françois c'est
très facile à rebonds ray fascine que
vont-ils faire regarde c'est tout voilà
le roux des objets trouvés a alors nous
lisions dos un sac de dragées au poivre
rouge en regardant les objets trouvés
waouh bas j'ai effectivement cet article
minutes attend
sa branche et pour ça
il faut
il en vaut 25 ah oui mais il y a cinq
francs pour le bureau les objets perdus
5 francs pour le bureau des objets
trouvés ça fait bien liffran ouais
vobruba écoute tu vas les avoir c'est
différent mais je m'en souviendrai un
m'aidera j'ai perdu sur six va donner
mais non j'ai les cartes avaient bien
l'intention d'en damman les offrira
enfin alors merci julie merci et casimir
et ses bureaux toujours à votre service
asie miremont jamais mais c'est très mal
au nez de ce procédé julie faut surtout
pas se laisser faire à je vois monsieur
veut poser une réclamation
d'accord voilà c'est très simple
adressez vous au bureau des réclamations
alors je signale qu'il ya des
réclamations à 5 francs de réclamation à
10 francs et des réclamations à 15
francs kazemi aider les états unis en
sont quasi mystique no no no 6 se fera
dans deux entretiens entre le ferons
je vois françois que toi aussi tu as
perdu quelque chose ah qu'est-ce que
j'ai perdu tu as perdu le sens de
l'humour à
[Musique]